the Republican tax plan is a big step
closer to success this morning the
sweeping overhaul passed the Senate
Budget Committee yesterday on a
party-line vote now that vote followed
another capitol hill visit from the
president Nancy Cordes is on Capitol
Hill with the plans new momentum Nancy
good morning good morning president
Trump heads to st. Charles Missouri
today to make one last big public push
for his party's tax plan and things do
seem to be moving in his direction
several key Republican holdouts say that
their issues are being addressed by the
president and Republican leaders at
least nine Republicans say they are
concerned about the bill in its current
form two of them have already said
they're against it how do you address
all of the concerns that some of these
GOP holdouts have it's a challenging
exercise senator Susan Collins of Maine
is seeking several amendments before
she's willing to endorse the bill
including reinstating the deduction for
property taxes up to ten thousand
dollars Collins had expressed concerns
about repealing Obama cares individual
mandate but said she was able to reach
an agreement to help people with
pre-existing conditions and to lower
premiums another holdout tennessee's bob
Corker said he was encouraged by an
agreement with GOP leaders to limit the
tax plans impact on the debt he had
pushed for a fiscal trigger that would
eliminate some of the tax cuts if the
bill fails to stimulate economic growth
President Trump left a luncheon with
Senate Republicans upbeat about the
bills chances somewhat of a love fest
they want to see it happen there were
even more fireworks yesterday in the
fight over funding the government
Democratic leaders Nancy Pelosi and
Chuck Schumer pulled out of a plan
meeting with the president at the last
minute after he tweeted that he didn't
expect that there would be a deal in
response the president set up a photo-op
at the meeting to show the Democrats
empty seats even having the Republican
leaders sit farther away from him
to accommodate that image all right
Nancy Cordes on Capitol Hill Thank You
Nancy